[Musique]
charlotte poussins bonjour bonjour
vernis merci d'être sur le plateau télé
fils vous êtes yvelinoise et vous êtes
avant tout une spécialiste la méthode
montessori vous êtes éducatrice vous
êtes auteur de nombreux ouvrages et
coffrets et maman de cinq enfants aussi
voilà qui voit là c'est et scolarisés en
école montessori d'accord alors est ce
qu'on peut déjà pour un premier point
expliquer ce qu'est la méthode
montessori d'abord qui est cette fameuse
maria montessori alors mal à montessori
est l'une des premières femmes médecins
d'europe italienne elle est né en 1870
et elle a fait preuve d'énormément de
cours à une époque où les études de
médecine était réservé aux nobles déjà
celles ayant une femme très avant
gardiste a fait aussi beaucoup pour la
cause des femmes et elle a découvert
auprès des enfants cette pédagogie
montessori sans la créer c'est ce qu'il
disait mais simplement en observant les
enfants qui eux lui ont dit ce dont ils
avaient besoin lui ont révélé les lois
naturelles de leur développement et elle
a donc prôné le respect l'observation et
le respect de ses élans que les enfants
oui quand vous dites que les enfants lui
ont révélé
c'est elle qui est tu les regardes est
due à bonneuil avec un oeil médical
chante ici
elle a été comme une chercheuse elle
s'est inspirée de deux pédagogues
médecins aussi jean itard et edward ce
gain de français qui avait conçu au
siècle précédent du matériel pédagogique
pour les enfants déficients
ah oui là déjà parce qu'elle a commencé
à s'occuper d'enfants en difficulté tout
à fait elle s'est d'abord tourné là les
enfants porteurs de handicap et elle
leur a proposé ce matériel dans une
forme d'apprentissage très individualisé
personnalisé et ils ont fait de tels
progrès qu'elle leur a proposé de passer
les examens les mêmes que ceux des
enfants non porteurs d'un handicap
et oui d'accord et lui des résultats
similaires voire meilleur c'est
incroyable et à partir de ce moment là
elle s'est dit mais qu'est ce qui peut
entraver le développement des enfants
non porteurs de handicap est
effectivement l'école il ya un siècle
était assez stricte
10h04 le moins qu'on puisse dire et elle
a révolutionné le regard que l'adulte
posait sur l'enfant alors aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup
un phénomène de mode on parle de
pédagogie nouvelle alors que c'est vrai
que c'est des intuitions qu'elle avait
eu en suivant aussi d'autres pédagogue
qui l'avaient précédé mais c'est une
très vieille intuition qu'il s'agit de
suivre l'élan naturel de l'apprentissage
de l'enfant d'accord alors vous vous
avez commencé par écrire un premier
ouvrage apprends moi à faire seul
voilà qui concerne alors je le montre
voilà l hérédité sous cette couverture
avant il était jaune voilà maintenant il
est comme ça c'est dit réédité grâce à
son succès évidemment il a été traduit
en plusieurs langues notamment aux
chinois et aux roumains en turc en
espagnol commence à un grand succès un
grand intérêt surtout et alors ce livre
qu'est-ce qui le qu'est-ce qui prône
alors apprends moi car seul ça on vise
quel public alors apprendre à faire
c'est vrai que c'est la phrase
emblématique de la proche montessori
dont le grand but et l'autonomie qui
favorise la confiance en soi parce que
c'est une approche qui met en avant
surtout avant tout les le développement
non cognitif part ça veut dire quoi ça
les toutes les qualités sociales le
savoir être ensemble la confiance en soi
l'estimé de soi
tout ce qui permet d'avoir de mon
apprentissage académique aussi mais
surtout chez un seul perdant
personnalité une vraie mission il l'a
prise de conscience de ce pourquoi en
effet bah oui d'accord là donc en fait
elle part du principe cette ce docteur
maria montessori qu'on a tous sont soit
des capacités différentes les unes des
les uns des autres
voilà et que l'udc du jour a limité les
découvre
rk plus on va aller vers ce pourquoi en
effet plus on va exceller
donc l'idée s'est trouvé l'idée dans
chaque enfant enfin aider l'enfant à
trouver exactement l'accompagné l'enfant
pour qu'il apprenne à être lui-même et
qu'il devienne lui même et non pas celui
que l'on souhaite qu'il devienne
d'accord voilà
et ça c'est pas acquis aujourd'hui on
attendait les jeunes parents modernes
je pense que les jeunes parents modernes
n'a effectivement ne sont pas ceux d'il
ya un siècle
donc ils ont cassé mais encore il ya
encore beaucoup de parents qui revivait
un petit peu leur vie à travers celle de
leurs enfants ou qu'ils aient investi ce
peut-être de manière un petit peu
dirigiste parfois au lieu de d'observer
de suivre la personne qui est l'enfant
qui est un avis du à part entière et non
pas un futur adulte que l'on modèle que
l'on façonne pour qu'il devienne ce que
l'on souhaite pour lui donc je parle
n'est pas forcément fasciné par un
enfant qui leur semblerait pas oui
certains parents des projets très précis
et c'est pas une conversation peut-être
poids lourd à porter oui oui oui comme
ça c'est pas du tout faits pour ça oui
c'est juste qu'on vit dans la lutte
alors du coup wi fi dans la lutte tout à
fait c'est quelque chose sur lequel
heures maria montessori insister
beaucoup cette espèce de coup free de
génération perpétuelle qui se reproduit
de génération en génération et elle son
objectif c'était vraiment de rompre ce
cycle de ne pas faire en sorte que
l'adulte reproduisent exactement ce
qu'il avait reçu en dix ans moi de toute
façon moi j'ai pas été traumatisé donc
le sait pas parce que j'ai reçu trois
claques et comment empêcher de faire
médecine alors que vous accueillez qu'on
m'a obligé à faire avocat que je vais
mal m'en tirer et en fait c'est ça
l'idée l'idée c'est peut-être que moi on
m'a forcé au mas diriger c'est pas une
raison pour que moi je dirige et force
c'est pas parce que j'ai souffert et je
m'en suis sorti que il faut que je
souhaite à mon enfant de souffrir voilà
donc c'est un grand message en fait
actuel donc vous avez donc écrit ce
premier livre donc des 3 à 6 ans voilà
il ya aussi des coffrets parce que
montessori c'est ce sont des concepts
qui vont avec du matériel bien précis
bien adapté on voit d'ailleurs le
coffret à l'écran et vous en avez donc
conçu plusieurs alors dit mans allait
l'être rugueuse que s'il y avait alors
les les chiffres rugueux les lettres
rugueuse
ça s'est vidée pouvoir toucher voilà
nous permettent d'apprendre en
appliquant tous les sens d'apprendre à
compter et à reconnaître les lettres
mais parce qu'ils préparent
indirectement à la lecture et à
l'écriture en même temps dans une
approche vraiment multisensorielle
puisqu'on voit on touche on prononce la
lettre tout en n'imprimant le mouvement
que l'on fait pour la trace est d'accord
et de cette manière avec l'aide de ce
coffret j'apprends à lire avec
montessori on toutes les étapes
d'apprentissage de la lecture ils sont
bien spécifié pour les parents puissent
accompagner son enfant dans cet
apprentissage qui peut être très joyeux
facile alors que beaucoup de parents
stressent et transmettre ce stress à
leurs enfants
alors est ce qui n'est pas une condition
donc l'apprentissage justement joyeux
facile et agréable
si vous quittons bonbons exactement là
d'un déguisement un peu plus sur ce
concept
mais c'est le secret c'est de repérer à
quel moment l'enfant a soif de lire et à
ce moment là lui présenter le bon
matériel au bon moment dans les bonnes
doses et tout se passe à merveille de
façon très ludique
c'est un coffret qui est crise on n'a
pas une boîte de chocolats qui est
rempli de petites fiches de petits
tickets de lecture d'image avec toujours
le moyen de s'auto corriger et une
approche très évolutive de manière à ce
que l'enfant avance à son rythme déjà
alors par landry ça veut dire que tout
le monde n'a pas envie de lire aux mêmes
ont même âge déjà donc ça peut commencer
très tôt ou plus tard et comment est-ce
qu'on repère un enfant qui a soif de
l'apprentissage eh bien on repère parce
que l'enfant pose des questions aux
adultes
d autres enfants qui l'entourent ils
cherchent à déchiffrer reconnaît son
prénom il essaye d'accord ils montrent
un intérêt à être et c'est à ce moment
là faut en effet présenté le matériel
d'accord même si les pensées paix enfin
ah oui tout à fait certains enfants
apprennent à lire à 4 ans et d'autres 6
et il n'y a aucune notion d' avance de
retard et il n'y a pas de raison de s'en
enorgueillir parce que l'enfant litho ça
ne ça n'est pas prédictifs de ce qu'il
va vivre plus tard c'est juste
l'occasion quand on nous promet de beaux
moments de faire un apprentissage joyeux
et tout apprentissage spontanée et
joyeux conditionne plus de sa vie en
tissage suivant pas la plus voilà c'est
de la même manière qu'un enfant apprend
à marcher spontanément sans avoir pris
de court
on peut apprendre à compter on peut
apprendre à lire et à écrire avec cette
espèce de sensation de fluidité défi -
parce que ça correspond à un besoin et
une envie inné chez l'enfant mais que du
coup ça sera avec plaisir
voilà c'est le secret c'est sacré
voilà alors on n'en est pas resté là
parce que vous êtes allé sont de comment
dire études j'ai encore en amont les
bébés et vous avez sorti un autre livre
récent celui ci plus récents qui parle
de l'enfant de 0 à 3 ans alors ça ça
n'existait pas déjà
alors il n'y avait pas de livres
spécifiquement sur la pédagogie
montessori de la naissance à 3 ans maria
montessori on a beaucoup parlé
oui mais là elle n'a pas dédié ou
consacré un livre à ce budget voilà
voilà
et quand j'étais enceinte de mon
cinquième enfant j'ai eu envie de relire
toute son oeuvre
ouais alors que j'étais déjà éducatrice
via la plagne est bien imprégné déjà
passé 15 ans en classe de diriger une
école montessori
là j'ai eu l'occasion de relire toute
son oeuvre avec le regard de la petite
enfance
donc vous avez cherché tout ce qui
concernait le bébé même in utero jusqu'à
trois ans tout à fait parce que même une
du terreau elle en parle
oui oui
l'importance de la naissance de la
qualité des soins et de tout l'accent
qu'il faut mettre sur la qualité de la
relation parce que le petit est un être
qui vit qui se nourrit de relations de
sérénité de repères et qu'il a besoin
d'ordre d'amour je peux avoir peur de ce
mot et elle insistait sur le maternage
là forcément on porte l'enfant dont on
lui parle on s'adresse à lui
l'importance de la richesse du langage
que l'on emploie quand on s'adresse à
l'huile et la petite aux forces dé la dé
la vie à des rails terry 20 minutes
menés dès la première minute mais même
avant la naissance oui la prise de
conscience de cet être qui grandit en
nous
comment on fait pour quand il est dans
le ventre des quand il est dans le
ventre alors ça elle n'en parlait pas
avec les termes qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui puisque aujourd'hui on parle
d'haptonomie n'était pas à l'époque
n'ont en tout cas pas dans ces termes là
mais instinctivement les femmes
rentraient déjà fait en relation avec
leur enfant parent n'était au sens du
toucher et ont pensé aussi un en
communion de pensée
oui bah oui je porte qu'instinctivement
beaucoup de femmes le faisait d'accord
c'est vrai que l'haptonomie invite à
prendre conscience de cette relation que
vous créez un à côté de grève voilà des
l'agora la princesse ok donc en fait ce
qu'il faut dire pour vous il ya plein de
choses à dire mais c'est contre 0 et 3
ans finalement c'est là où se font ce qu
mondiale et socle de la passe a été de
l'enfance secret oui et donc c'est hyper
important
oui tout à fait et donc on va marcher
par comment elle appelle çà s'est j'ai
entre les périodes sensibles voilà les
palettes 106 wissant de mauvais des
périodes pendant lesquelles l'enfant à
des sensibilités très forte qui le
pousse à se tourner vers certains
éléments de son environnement
d'accord qu'il a besoin à ce moment là
pour apprendre ok bon voila moi j'invite
tout le monde à lire ce livre
et puis après vous avez un projet aussi
bientôt vous allez sortir encore un
nouveau livre décidément ça n'arrête pas
mais alors là m c'est pas tout à fait
moi qu'il sort mais j'ai eu
vous avez traduit oui j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir l'opportunité de traduire le
dernier livre de maria montessori qui
n'étaient pas traduits en français rien
d'autre mais qui va sortir dans la
foulée aux éditions desclée de brouwer
qui a une excuse en cas ça va être le
texte voilà c'est un texte de maria
montessori qui s'achève le manuel
pratique de la méthode montessori
d'accord voilà
bon bah écoutez génial merci pour ce
cadeau à offrir à s'offrir et puis voilà
parfait cadeau de naissance
oui merci charlotte remercie avoir pour
votre insertion
[Musique]